Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my brand new Spider-Man 4 video
There's a bunch of great news that we just heard.
They're getting ready to start filming the movie
Tom Holland's been talking about a little bit, too,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's going to be a lot of Spider-Man
related stuff happening in 2024 and 2025.
So like we have the Spider-Man freshman year TV show
that's coming at the end of 2024.
they've actually renamed
that Friendly neighborhood Spider-Man.
I think to avoid some confusion
about where it fits in the multiverse
in the grand scheme of things,
I already did a much bigger trailer video about that.
So I'll link it at the end of this.
There's like a big 2024 push into animation
that Marvel is doing during 2024, like X-Men 97.
in, it is full.
More Ben time in 2024 for Sony.
Like there's the Madame Web movie
which is kind of like Morbius for women.
And then there's also the Kraven movie.
It's Kraven time coming later in the year.
one of the funny things about Tom Holland's
Spider-Man four, even though it's like their big
marquee movie, there's a bit of a tug of war
happening behind the scenes between Marvel and Sony is
do how connected it's going to be to that Venom
spinoff universe.
basically, Sony wants it to be full more Ben
time for Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
like bring him into our universe
because there was that big Morbius Post-Credits scene
where they reference Spider-Man in his big Sinister
Six spin off movie setting up.
They want to have a big sinister
Six franchise separately from the Venom
movies and all these other movies.
That's where they're setting it up
in the Morbius Post-Credits scene.
Apparently they really want that Spider-Man
to be Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
even though there are a number
of other available spider-men that they could use,
like Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man,
they could even use live action.
Miles Morales is they're not going to be
making that movie for a couple more years.
would give Sony a bunch of time to release Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse
and complete Miles Morales
arc in the Spider-Verse movies,
which Lord and Miller basically said would happen
like at the end of Beyond the Spider-Verse.
That will be the end of Miles Morales storyline,
at least in those movies.
I think that's just because when Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse came out a while ago,
Amy Pascal revealed that they had plans to do
a live action Miles Morales movie.
So they're planning to transition to him
inside their big Sony universe of Marvel characters,
or the Venom Universe.
However you want to think about it.
But probably some of the best news
so far about Spider-Man four
is that Marvel wants to keep it a very ground
level friendly neighborhood.
Spider-Man kind of a vibe in the movie
with a lot of Daredevil in it, and the Kingpin
character there have been so many rumors about them
since the events of Spider-Man No Way Home.
Like you have that quick Daredevil
cameo scene and like the extended version,
you have a little bit more Daredevil in it.
there's some of the greatest energy
together, and Daredevil is probably
one of the other preeminent ground level characters
inside the Marvel Universe.
And they're basically trying to take Spider-Man
in a more ground level direction, more friendly
neighborhood.
Spider-Man direction way less of the iron Man, way
less tech, like more lo fi, just in general,
much less of a big multiverse movie,
which I think a lot of people will be excited about.
even though Spider-Man No Way Home was amazing
with all the full multiverse stuff that it got into.
I think we're getting to the point where the multiverse
saga in Marvel has gotten a little long in the tooth.
People are ready to have Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty, Avengers six,
Secret Wars, and to move past the multiverse arc.
supposedly the plan and Spider-Man four
is to still have it
take place before Avengers five in Avengers six,
but just to keep it
a little more self-contained, like less multiverse
stuff going on than there was during Spider-Man.
No Way Home.
one of the only problems with that, though,
is that Sony still has a lot of control,
even though Marvel technically, per
their sharing contract,
has most of the creative control over
what happens in that movie.
But there's just like a big argument
going on behind the scenes in Obviously,
Marvel wants to continue using Spider-Man
after the Spider-Man four movie in Avengers five.
so do not be surprised if you continue
to hear arguments about Marvel and Sony going back and
forth about how connected Tom Holland is going to be
to this Sony universe of Marvel characters
until Spider-Man four actually comes out
and we see those Post-Credits scenes
they're still trying to release the movie
by summer 2025, like July 2025.
That's usually the target date
for most Spider-Man movies.
but if they don't actually start filming
the movie really soon, they're going to miss that date.
So they'd have to release it either Christmas 2025,
which isn't that big of a deal, or push it to 2026.
But in reality, they've delayed most of the Marvel
movies that were going to happen next year to 2025.
So they're going to delay Spider-Man for a year.
That's not a huge deal either
Tom Holland has issued a couple official statements
like His official stance
is that he'll just continue playing Spider-Man forever.
Basically, as long as there are good scripts.
He's not going to film a movie
just to film a Spider-Man movie.
he said that right after the strikes.
And that's probably just code for
we're not quite done with the script yet.
So like,
the movie doesn't look exactly like a full movie yet.
The funny thing about Spider-Man,
No Way Home, too, is that he said that
the script changed every single day
they were filming on that movie.
And if you asked him what the big third act
final battle with the Statue of Liberty was going to be
when they started filming the movie,
he would have had no idea because they hadn't
even finished writing that scene yet in fact,
I talked about this during my Spider-Man
No Way Home deleted scenes videos
because there were many deleted scenes
that were like many different versions of the movie
with many different types of team ups.
If they did not have Tobey Maguire in Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man, like they had a bunch of contingency plans.
for instance, we had that Venom crossover scene
in the Post-Credits scene.
Originally, he was actually meant to be
at that big Statue of Liberty battle.
He would have been a much bigger character,
which is why during the Post-Credits scene,
he talks about going to New York City
to talk to Spider-Man.
Originally, that scene was going to come much earlier
in the movie, and he would have gone to New York City
in fought in that big final fight, probably explaining
how Tom Holland's Spider-Man winds up
getting the symbiote, too,
because he would let the pieces of the symbiote closer
to New York City, where it would come into contact
with Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
as far as I know, though, Spider-Man
four will not be the actual start of the symbiote saga.
They're pushing that off
just like a little bit later in the story,
but they might tease it a little bit during the movie.
Like the symbiote piece might get a little bit closer
to him in some of the post-credits scenes,
But it sounds like Daredevil is a much bigger
part of the story, even though Kingpin
would not be like the main villain right now,
The antagonists that are in the movie are villains.
However you want to think about them or kingpin
in the Vulture character coming back.
The funny thing about The Vulture coming back
is that he was also in a bunch of deleted scenes
from Spider-Man No Way Home.
Like if you look at the scene
here, he's clearly taking the Sinister Six
characters to the Vulture's house
to try and deal with them.
I don't know how far this got into production
before they decided to remove the vulture.
I think they just got too overstuffed with characters
and they had Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man.
It's like, okay, we have them.
We don't need to have like a billion other characters.
but just like Kingpin.
Obviously Vulture would not be the main villain again.
Like, he'd just be one of the antagonists in the movie
that would also help Spider-Man
at some point during the film, they haven't said
who the actual main villain is going to be.
It would probably be a brand new Spider-Man villain
from the comics that they have not done in the MCU yet.
but you can kind of see with all these deleted scenes
from the previous Spider-Man movies,
even like the Morbius movie,
with all the Spider-Man stuff in it that they removed
before the actual release of the movie.
All the Venom stuff
That early on, they were actually planning
to have a Spider-Man
versus Venom movie much, much earlier.
But I think the idea is
they just came up with a much stronger idea
for what they wanted the Spider-Man movies to be.
So like, you know, we don't need all this big crossover
stuff with Venom, Morbius, all the Sony stuff,
it sounds like the movie is still supposed to come out
after the events of Daredevil Born Again.
So Kingpin will become mayor of New York City
during Daredevil
born again,
even though they've changed the plot of that.
I'll explain that in a second.
There have been a bunch of changes
behind the scenes with Daredevil Born Again.
but part of the idea is that Vincent D'Onofrio teased
that he would go up against the Spider-Man
eventually a while ago.
And it sounds like they're actually going to finally
pay that off in some way, even though, like I said,
he probably won't be the main villain of the movie
I mean, there's only one really and go.
You know, and I think somebody just said who
would get hurt?
That's Spider-Man director.
so you guys have no idea what you're in store for.
And yet.
I know.
all that kingpin stuff.
Kingpin becoming
mayor of New York City is part of that big Marvel Phase
five dark reign that they have going on
in the background with villains.
Slowly coming to power
is like a loose adaptation of Dark Reign in the comics
with some different characters.
previously I would have said this
all spins out of what happened
at the end of secret invasion with the US President.
Ritson Basically going full nuclear on the skrulls
like we are going to clamp down hard.
It will be like a military state around the world
till we get rid of all these skrulls.
but because they flubbed secret invasion so hard.
Like there were so many complaints
about the secret invasion series.
I think they're just trying to avoid
referencing secret invasion as much as possible.
so even though the ending of that series with the U.S.
president precipitates a lot of the dark reign stuff
that's happening across all the movies
and all the TV shows, I think they'll just avoid
mentioning the events of Secret Invasion
as much as possible.
I've already done
videos about Zendaya coming back and Spider-Man four.
I don't know about Ned leads coming back.
There was all these jokes about him becoming a version
of Hobgoblin in the previous Spider-Man movies.
So people are like,
Are they going to do that in Spider-Man four?
Finally, there are even deleted scenes from Spider-Man
No Way Home with him on Green Goblin's Glider,
going full hobgoblin
like they're clearly referencing him
becoming hobgoblin because he's throwing
one of the pumpkin bombs during this.
but I don't think that they're going there
in Spider-Man four.
Like, I think this was just an idea for Spider-Man,
no way home that they decided
not to do at the last minute.
So they're just kind of leaving it off like,
we could always do this in the future
if we want, but probably not.
over on the dirt of a born again
side of things you probably see, I did a couple videos.
They basically canceled the original version
of Daredevil Born Again
because Kevin Foggy apparently saw all the dailies
and just hated what they were doing.
It basically turned the show
into more of a legal procedural like law and order
type of show with not a lot of daredevil in it,
not a lot of action either.
It used
people would just be super pissed off if you saw
a daredevil show without Daredevil
doing a lot of Daredevil stuff.
so they basically fired the previous creative team on
that show, hired a bunch of the Punisher Netflix people
in a bunch of the Loki people after Loki season two
to redo that show with some of the existing footage.
but there's a bunch of big stuff coming up in 2024.
We still have that animated Spider-Man show.
Of course I'll do episode videos for that.
we probably won't get a trailer for that for a while.
But I have done a couple teaser
trailer videos and trailer videos for the stuff
that they have released already.
Click here for that Spider-Man
freshman year trailer video to learn what's going on
with that series and click here for my X-Men 97 teaser
trailer video to learn what's going on with that.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!